hello everybody welcome back to big food
it's a big mood in here this is a bonus
episode of so are you even ready for it
we don't really do these type of
episodes ever I don't think we've ever
done a T episode but we're super
interested in this when it exploded and
we've been talking about it in the group
chat and I feel like the whole podcast
big mood is our group chat so whatever
we share in there we share with you and
this was the hottest topic especially
since it's a female podcast they talk
about sex we relate to them a lot like I
feel like we're in the same kind of
category of podcasts and so they're just
like way bigger than us they have less
women but way bigger yeah yeah like so
when y'all hear about money and [ __ ]
that they're making honey we're not yeah
pull the other one way one day actually
that's actually part of it is because
part of it is that Barstow sports owned
them as a show and put a lot of money
into marketing so they're numb they blew
up they are great as a show but also
they were in conjunction with Barstow
sports which had a lot of marketing
budget so that's part of it and that's
part of what happened do does anyone
else want to explain what went down or
summarize it um so basically there's a
awesome podcast called call it color
daddy and yes two girls it's Alex and
Sophia yeah let's preface this like I
never watched the show but I there i I
don't think any of us like watch a show
or our fans of the show but like we kind
of get them a little bit but like it's
it's not it's not often that content
creators consume the same content that
you create just so y'all know like we're
not haters of them we we respect them
like it's it's really quite late yeah I
related for sure I bonded through
similar sure yeah yeah so it's two girls
it's so cute it's a blonde brunette the
blonde is Alex the brunette is Sophia
and they were dude they were what best
friends and roommates I
a hundred percent sure but they're
definitely friends they were best
friends and then they basically had a
podcast together with Arsenal sports and
it became like this huge sensation they
were like all over the place like I
don't even listen to podcasts or
anything but I've even heard cuz I'm you
know and um very successful and I guess
the short story is one of them started
dating a dude he started putting ideas
in her head saying you should be making
a lot more money than this well this
dude it's not just any duty there he's
an HBO Sports an HBO executive yeah yeah
yeah oh I didn't really know that yeah
he was stating he's dating Sofia and he
told her like you were not making as
much money should there's an industry
standard of how much you shouldn't
making that got into her head like wait
a minute how much should we be making
and then so she and Alex tried to
renegotiate their contract with barstool
and Nikki you can talk business better
than I do God okay so from what I
understand and I've tried to watch all
of the videos and all of their
perspectives but from what I understand
they were they were told that you're not
making industry-standard which to some
degree is true and we'll talk about that
but you know they think people got in
their ear like you guys should be making
way more money and their numbers did
reflect that the show was making a lot
more than what they were getting paid as
hosts and so um you know this guy the
HBO's that could have created a draft to
kind of like renegotiate their contract
because they were allowed to renegotiate
their contract every year and that's
very that's very standard to me will
turn your renegotiate your contract
because you don't know if the show's
gonna take off off or not and it was
also in their contract that they could
renegotiate your contract so that's
that's totally normal and they
renegotiated and they but their demands
we're really high so they had asked for
a million dollars and the IP of the show
amongst other things but those would
like to talk to and I was like I don't
know though can you explain what IP is
oh yeah IP is intellectual property and
so basically it's the whole concept of
the show so whoever owns the IP for
example big mood we all own the IP if
one of us tried if we did it on the
P which they didn't at the time barstool
sports owned it if we didn't own the IP
for big mood we can't walk away and
still call with big mood yeah we can't
reference big mood it can't any like
inside games or anything that was made
it to merge anything that turned a
profit anything that was trademarked or
any any of that we like step on your
neck like Gino couldn't say that so the
catch phrases and things like that that
they had been using for marketing and
they had been using and creating a brand
from they would have to essentially give
up to partial sports who owned the IP
and so when they were asking for 1
million dollars plus the IP complete
ownership of the IP that's a huge a
specious entually they can walk away
from barstool sports and still make all
of that advertising money off of this
brand that they've created and not let
barstool sports have any of the money
and then I would ran that bar slow
sports had actually blown up what their
marketing thing that's and why they
owned it like they gave up because I
think the girls started the show before
even Parcells sports got barely I think
it was barely yeah but then they like
bought it and so they owned it so yeah
and so yeah contracts is like with the
contract both parties have to have
something to get something out of it so
if they were to negotiate that hey we're
taking everything and we want a million
dollars off of you
of course parcel is gonna be like it
[ __ ] you know the owner of bar so was
like go [ __ ] yourself like this is funny
[Music]
yeah so okay so when you join it they
had done four episodes on their own
before going to barstool and negotiating
this contract where barstool essentially
bought the show they like picked up the
show we own IP we're gonna pay you guys
a talent fee to host the show like
employees basically the employee hasn't
there of their own show I mean they
created it but they agreed to sell it
basically for an exchange for barstool
marketing them and you know basically
producing the whole thing which is
awesome imagine starting like that's
what good one you make a show you homies
you sell it yeah and you hope that
housing
and the Alex was even talking about her
video how she was on unemployment at the
time and so when that happens because no
one else you are you don't know if your
shows gonna do well on your own you're
kind of making a deal with a bigger
entity that though they'll boost yours
status and more people will know you
which is exactly what happened but
because the contract was negotiated that
they were talent they they were getting
paid a fee and they didn't really have
rights to that IP anymore because they
were contractually like they were
employees and they agreed to that for
the money which is great because
sometimes it takes a podcast months and
two years to earn any money so the fact
that they were getting $75,000 each off
the bat was a really good deal for them
yeah and eventually they negotiated to
get like some bonuses and some raises
cuz then by the end of the first year
they're already making more because it's
a three yeah yeah are you making more
than what they were supposed to be
making for like the next few years so
that's why they were renegotiating they
made a lot they made a lot more than I
think at first it kind of leaked out
like oh they're making they got a shitty
ask on track because everyone knew they
blew up real quick within a few months
and then someone leaked out like Oh
their contracts only 75 thousand but
they're getting all these [ __ ] views
like even we heard that like before any
of this drama months and months and
months ago we heard like you know these
girls have the [ __ ] end of the stick in
their bono contract so that's all I ever
heard of that previously there's so much
more to the story
it's unusual for the podcast hosts to
not own the show to not own the IP
because it is pretty easy to start a
podcast I mean like for us we have
producers and stuff so that's awesome
but I mean if you went to bare-bones you
could start up you could start a podcast
right now like there's no in there's no
minimum for you to start a podcast
anybody can start in so usually the
hosts own the show since they're the
face of it they're they're the ones
marketing it promoting it they're the
ones they're the face of the show it's
unusual to have a show blow up that big
when they're the the hosts were just
Talent and so that's why it was like
whoa did you know they're only getting
paid this and they don't own the show
and like it's it
that was the big deal about that but in
reality though like with all the bonuses
that I mean barstool moved will say move
the goalposts for them every time they
deserved it from what I gather from the
story they they continue to upgrade
their pay their bonuses and everything
like as they were making more and more
money as time went by like the end of
that first year they were making a lot
of money they were yeah but if you have
so many people from like in the industry
telling you like you're not getting
industry I mean obviously and you don't
know it enough like you're gonna think
you're getting screwed so I totally feel
for them because like when you're new
and you don't know anything you're just
gonna trust who you can and so they went
in there asked for a million dollars and
the whole reasoning was well if we ask
for a million they'll come down to like
ule minutes in the middle like 500k or
whatever and um you know their first
initial reaction from barstool was
terrible they were like go [ __ ] yourself
that was a shirt um and then they ended
up having another meeting where is his
name David Dave Portman anyway
yeah even the owner of barstool yeah
yeah so they had a meeting on his
rooftop deck in New York and he actually
agreed to half a million dollars and
giving them IP would you Jenny not those
six months of their contract or
something right like that eighty left
are the best [ __ ] deal if I was I was
so dick for that [ __ ] contract I know
the dip for that shitty oh my god pretty
no that's the finest bring what like
that was so nice of him to do that yeah
yeah yeah I was saying because of his
crisis is the reason why he gave of that
that he put that deal on the table
because he wanted to feed like his
employees pretty much by keeping the
show running but then Sophia apparently
had to get kind of greedy so they you
had that meeting and they were offered
500k and the IP and Alex was like
[ __ ] ecstatic because who wouldn't be
that's what you're a bully
amazing so feels like who knows what I
wanted like this isn't enough and then
just kind of shut on Alex's happiness
and joy and they had like an awkward
walk home to their apartment or whatever
like I don't understand why would you
not be happy about this and take the way
Nikki so basically it came down to Sofia
had different values for what she wanted
from the negotiation and what Alex
wanted Alex wanted to continue working
with barstool as long as they met their
criteria and they felt like they were
being taken care of
Sofia just wanted the IP and a walk away
and do their own thing and not have to
be tied to barstool anymore which why
would barstool just hand you the IP and
then be like being impatient and like in
yeah it's like you have to show some
level of respect for the people that put
you on the map like I get I get you
deserve and you want all of your like
you want to own this because you're
doing the content but at the same time
they blew you up
you're [ __ ] famous is [ __ ] now you're
making so much money just right out the
last [ __ ] few months of your contract
pay your dues and then move on you know
what it's called it's called [ __ ]
loyalty dude [ __ ] figure it out
sure a lot of people deal with the word
loyalty means but you know what um what
doesn't a say so you know how it's like
I don't know the timeline of things of
one day happened but apparently Sofia
found out that Alex was getting paid
because of the fact that Alex and it's
the show get extra work yeah she does
extra work so apparently it seems to be
from Sofia side that at them like the
time that she found this out the
betrayal is when she started like
sabotaging the entire show and that's
the reason why she kept moving the
goalposts every time an offer was placed
on the table because it just seemed like
no matter what she was already like she
was ready to [ __ ] on the show I don't
know if there was about remembers things
about that but there's I think she was
definitely salty [ __ ] that she found out
she was making more money but it's like
you weren't doing all things I added to
it to like make her yeah like make those
moves yeah this was it was our show and
then
went behind my back and got paid more I
get how you would feel that way and look
I'm not like being a Sofia hater I think
that like you just you only know what
you're being told and sometimes when you
find out one piece of information is
right you start your mind starts
spinning about like how much more you've
been scammed or like how much more have
people been ripping you off and then you
start to kind of go completely in the
opposite direction and I think that's
what happened to her and I don't I don't
blame her I just think that there's a
lot of learning curve there because on
the one hand yeah I mean you guys they
had a huge show they were making so
their show was making so much money they
could have been getting paid a little
bit more Barstow was open to it though
and so and they you know blew the show
up so I don't know yeah that is hard I
mean yeah she got paid more she didn't
work like Rea if Nikki start editing all
of our shows I would expect her to get
paid more than I mean are you hurt our
producers edit our show and guess what
they take a percentage of what little
money right now that we're getting
because it works yeah I think she just
I'm getting a sense of like entitlement
that's how it came off at least from
just from the videos and again don't
know their personal situation from the
videos is what it seems like just a
question though since I don't know
anything about their show how long have
they been on air they stay here long
Jesus Christ they blew up hard and they
blew up fast yeah I remember my first
podcast it's hard not to also like just
completely be in Sofia I mean like for
based on that what I watched which was I
watched Alex's video I listened to the
podcast that the owner of barstool like
interjected into the feed himself and I
saw like a little clip that I guess
Sofia did it's like a two minute thing I
don't know an Instagram live or whatever
but um like it's hard without hearing
her side of the story to like feel like
I can back her up at all cuz right now I
feel like I'm not even a fan of the show
but I'm like ride or die for this Alex
chick yeah
she came off a lot better and I related
harder to her especially when she said
the part about I wanted to do the show
for fun she wanted to edit long nights
she wanted to put a lot more hours into
it which editing is like a second job if
she was hosting being talent and doing
all the editing for it and she was
editing the video portion and making it
look more vlog style like that that is a
lot of work and it would take like three
days sometimes yeah and she really cared
and I do believe her that she started
the show cuz she wanted to have fun and
then the money was like an extra thing
that like wow that's crazy we can
actually make this much money and like
have a living off of it too and I think
that it looked at least from the videos
it seemed like Sophia once she got wind
of the money things started changing and
we can't leave town for cash saddest
thing ever it's like honestly like dude
like you guys I mean I don't know the
entire story right just based off of
whatever the surface I just feel really
sad for their friendship are you gonna
just let money get in between like that
and sadly it happens way too often does
well and and her you don't know if her
reps are telling her like you could do a
way bigger show without her now I'd like
we could go start this other show like
you don't know like when when someone's
new and vulnerable and yeah they just
you know they get a little bit of an ego
from what they've been told and what the
events that have happened and then they
think that like oh well I could have
this is way below me now and it makes me
oh whatever to do so yeah yeah that's
loyalty so important because if
seemingly Sophia was a lot more loyal to
her friend who apparently she started
dating this guy recently too it's like
they're not I'm not even like married or
whatever like long has a relationship
like she's loyal T's in the wrong place
exactly maybe she's beautiful she's head
over heels and smitten dude it's real
good person like right at
good job that she was set for I think
that's the answer it's up but she's
greedy or she's not loyal she's met her
trash there it is episodes over my min
are trash but guess what else is trash
your closet is wouldn't you love if
every clothing store you shop for
already understood your loves hates in
total No thank yous own well there's a
company focused on making that happen
and it's dish fix and you guys know
we've talked about them before you just
go online take a simple style quiz
they'll figure out who you are with what
type of [ __ ] you are what do you want
to wear and then they'll send you that
stuff it's super easy so if you don't
know stitch fix is a personal styling
company they bring you the world of
fashion to to your door it's a
completely different and fun way to find
clothes you'll love it's all about you
every time you pay just a twenty dollar
styling fee for each fixed which is
credited towards anything you keep and
you can schedule at any time there's no
subscription required so you don't have
to get it every month you can just kind
of get it pick and choose as you want
throughout the year
also plus shipping returns and exchanges
are easy and free I've known that my
first fix I had to return two items my
second one I kept everything but it was
super easy pants Oh pants are so comfy
yeah the pants are great every type of
pants I've kept stitch fix does the hard
work for you making it great style
effortless for everybody including women
women men and kids so get started today
at stitch fix comm slash mood and get an
extra 25% off when you keep everything
in your box
that's stitch fix comm slash mood mood
one last time stitch fix calm slash mood
thank you for supporting the show yeah
you know what else you gotta fix your
waiter prepare meals b-girl fresh gives
you mouth-watering seasonal so goodies
with pre measured ingredients delivered
right to your door like come on man I
absolutely despise cooking I know it's a
lot of people's passions we know sorry
like it's a dog but you know what hello
fresh actually makes it so fun to cook
because I don't have to stress like
literally everything is written down
right for me I just follow the recipe
like I said they give you pre measured
ingredients I don't have to think they
even tell me like how to like slice up
certain things so like I don't really
hold your hand every step of the way
like and like how you could make it look
like the picture yeah all right
pretty measurement and like there's a
picture to tell you how I like to set it
like the picture and then I do like on
TV what they what a clock and they clean
all the sauces yeah we do that every
dish Nikki oh wow I mean I really liked
this one salad I had a no exact name of
it I wish I had it in front of me but it
was like this salad with cotija cheese
that we haven't tried cherry the
charioteers how do I get it TIFF tell me
how I get it oh get America is number
one meal kits go - hello fresh comm /
big mood 10 and use the code big mood 10
for 10 free meals including free
shipping again go - hello fresh calm /
big mood 10 and use code big mood 10 for
10 free meals including free shipping
that's insane that's a lot of huge
discount I don't know how I could use 10
free meals ladies one thing that shocked
me too and I heard Alex's video is that
they spent three hours recording and
then and then she edits it down to one
hour like that is yeah that's a lot of
hard work I still didn't have their own
editing team or maybe she took it on
herself
I know when I'm carrying a bevel or hand
she and I think she had a vision because
she at least in her video I made it
sound like she was editing it like how
she hadn't seen any podcast do it before
it she's only she had more finger on the
pulse of what Millennials are like and
what they're into his shoes she wasn't
wrong to possession of blue the hardware
[ __ ] I appreciate that about him and
she's the one that took the initial
meeting with barstool to she's the one
that negotiated it I got them in the
door I feel like she did a lot of the
trailblazing and it can happen or at
least that's how it sounds and there's
much of the other side yes yeah like
it's I want to hear Sophia's side
because it's really hard to be on her
side right yeah real quiet I know I
really want to but it's really hard um
don't think that like blowing up that
fast especially when you're new is
almost a disservice because if you if
you didn't have to live through the
whole like struggling with a show and
struggling with your second show and
struggling with a third show before one
finally blows up I feel like you almost
don't appreciate what you have and you
don't and you don't know what every
standard is and you don't know what's
acceptable and what's not acceptable to
ask for and it you kind of get a little
bit of entitlement especially if your
fan base is somewhat not handed to you
because you still earned it but like you
know it was it came a lot easier than
almost other people it's almost a
disservice to the long-term life of your
business career and your mindset yeah I
feel like we felt a little bit of like
because when we first started this show
like we came out the gate we had
everyone we know like push it and
everything like and so we were getting
huge [ __ ] views in the beginning like
we we came out the gate with 500,000
views like we were all putting our yeah
when it was hey [ __ ]
and like after that it's kind of like we
had some issues with branding we had to
rebrand we couldn't own that IP anymore
and that kind of hurt us a little bit
and then there's some other things that
kind of just slowed down our progress
and we went from half a million views to
like 50,000 views and like us feeling
that struggle now I think it helps it's
like we needed that struggle and like
but also I don't I can't imagine like
break like it felt really good to get
those half a million views like almost
instantly right and then it's like if we
got a show immediately I can imagine
like oh my god like what yeah
would that have torn us apart like I I
don't think it would but I can't say
like who knows what could it have just I
felt the opposite and may
because I've been like a route like I've
been on YouTube for 12 years and I got
terrified when we hit high numbers I was
like this is not sustainable this is get
let down eventually because like I think
everyone was showing up for the height
but then it's like how many people are
really gonna stick in finish oh yeah
almost like we were set up almost for an
eventual failure and that was a little
bit scary and all the way we came
together was it was like a friend group
right like we're doing it for fun and it
we weren't expecting it to blow up like
that in the very beginning so when it
happened so quickly I was like oh no we
didn't have a chance for the fun part
like to develop our voice and our tone
and like how we are as a group and a
group dynamic and then numbers always
change people and I got really scared
about that yeah and that's what I liked
about our podcast because for the most
part everything most of us still stick
to like when we first came into this or
friends those were fun and if we make
money then sure [ __ ] awesome that's
why I never the number really never
bothered me I'm just like oh cool I get
to talk to my friends every week
otherwise I would never talk to anyone
ever because I don't write I'm sitting
here and it's getting darker and darker
do it can y'all see me yeah we're slowly
like a minute ratios like someone's just
like dialing the saturation down cuz you
know my white skin provides like its own
source of our ability to take this off
to do some kitchen play that's true
background enemy tribe your background
friend listen you know I have my animate
eyeballs t-shirt on I have a cinnamon
being a headband on game if gave this to
anything my buff day I still wear it
religiously and then animating for the
anime thing I decided to have half naked
anime men behind me the anime seemed
that none of us are part of you know
yeah we're gonna get the memo yeah today
I decided this was my fingering is paint
okay Wow double what's obtained finger
yeah we did you send up for a gangbang
so I think after that they offered that
and then they said that the girls have a
two-hour talk that's who I appreciation
figure out where to go with this what
you I commend them I commend them
because a lot of people might just [ __ ]
off and give you the ghost and just
don't even talk to you and be all
unprofessional and shitty or going on
your back and see some other [ __ ] but I
really commend them for having like a
two-hour conversation to try to figure
out like hey where do we want to go with
this but where is the effort to in that
respect for the friendship - I think
that they have yeah it because just like
exactly because then at that point like
you said you could just go sit and be
like oh we were never really friends you
know salvage I'm doing this thing over
here on my HBO boyfriend but the fact
that they still had the conversations
like the meetings like they were still
like negotiating like it was it was that
there was a lot of attempt there yeah
they whatever they had which like from
the outside I'm like that's tight like
I'm you know I didn't work out fine but
at least they did that you know it's
respectable is what it is they still
cared about each other's opinions and I
guess from what Alex said they couldn't
see eye to eye and like I think Sofia
wanted to leave barstool and Alex was
loyal to Barcelona wants to stay and
then what was that Nikki um that's
that's the last that I've heard I mean
Alex was doing the show herself now
though yeah I think that's still the
most update that we have so far there
hasn't been any new episodes after the
one that the owner of barstool
interjected yeah oh and the weird thing
okay I do you know royalty as you want
to say Alex a PD a second house I'm a
girl all dishes for you is for hosts
rely on me me just me I am the friend as
you can tell I'm the most brave digit
alter Univision
would pick you for sure your curling
your loyalty lastly a hundred percent
like if any of you guys actually got
selected for that I love you so much
that I would just be happy for you oh
that's a good ass good I would be like
you deserve it I don't I'm just so no I
can lame princess your tower I would
slash your tires but I would still I do
bring it something else though
because like I mean we're kind of
getting like we get in the contract
stuff and all that and that's probably
like a little bit boring for most people
they're like yeah I get it they're
greedy or whatever which they were but
there was another interesting take that
I got off of this website the
Federalists and I don't know anything
about this website but this person wrote
this article and the title of the
article is call her daddy podcast
debacle exposes the faux feminist
charade and so I wanted to touch on this
a little bit because when I read this it
really kind of it kind of emotionally
affected me a little bit the way that
this this person was talking about the
girls and their show in their content or
whatever and I guess apparently people
are kind of roasting Sophia now because
they're saying like oh they were these
like super feminist super like in-charge
independent [ __ ] whatever but then at
the end of the day Sophia lets this guy
come in and influence her and basically
[ __ ] up her life which is like sort of
going against the branding that they've
been building with like being the
daddies or whatever which I guess is
they're they're like thing yeah
so I wanted to discuss like the towards
the end of this article it says openly
bragging and discussing your libertine
sex life does not make you a feminist
but women like Cooper and Franklin were
raised in a cultural pond that elevated
feminists to be authorities on female
happiness feminists agree that happiness
and power are derived from sexual
liberation even though women in the
throes of hookup culture find themselves
feeling more depressed and less powerful
the economics of hookup culture means an
increasing number of
our course and entitled and women who
feel used and discarded the call her
daddy champions this brand of carefree
no-strings-attached feminism yet behind
closed doors deals are made as if there
are indeed some strings attached to
physical relationships we don't know for
certain how much nelson is to blame for
his girlfriend's negotiating blunder but
it should not be lost on any female call
her daddy fans that these women launched
a successful brand off the idea of
ultimate sexual freedom only to lose it
all because of a man now okay so this
has been something that's kind of
affected me a little bit personally not
the caller daddy stuff but this idea of
like how you know cuz we have similar
content right like we talked about being
sexually liberated we talked about like
you know maybe hone it up doing whatever
and like I feel like for me I want to
delineate like pull back the curtain and
delineate the difference between like
when we have fun on the show and we talk
about things like there's I like to call
this like women's locker room talk and
it's a little bit like yeah we kind of
play up the sexual liberation thing too
but and maybe this is like a personal
issue I have with like people thinking
that oh we're just like touting being a
[ __ ] and that's our strength and our
power and stuff but I don't really feel
like that's necessarily the case and I
feel like these caller daddy girls also
got kind of shoved into this corner of
like oh they're just [ __ ] and they're
and then now look at they're just really
stupid [ __ ] and it bothers me a
little bit too sometimes I don't even
want to tell people about the podcast
because I'm like we're having fun and
we're talking about sexual things but
for some reason when people hear that
and especially guys and even guys I've
dated they hear us talking about all
these sexual things and they think we're
just kind of like bimbos and we're dumb
and we're just [ __ ] and they they
don't respect what we're doing and I get
that a little bit but there's also like
there's a difference between like us
kind of having fun on the podcast and
like making you know like jokes about
[ __ ] different guys and all of that
but it's like there's a little bit of an
issue that I have with with making these
women out to be stupid [ __ ] and I
don't know if you guys can like jump in
on that a little bit but
that just sounds like a very angry man
an angry little man like oh yes I'm
totally a dumb stupid bimbo that doesn't
know anything I mean how else could I
ever start this podcast and do the
marketing and the editing and the
negotiating on the contract drafting
like yeah I'm totally a [ __ ] dumb
idiot just like a hater like that they
just don't like the fact that so a lot
of these guys it's kind of like the real
red pill community people be like yeah
like the in cells guys where they just
see women as a threat and they don't
like the fact that especially now in
like modern culture how we're not
submissive like in past generations and
it seems to like really rub something
like certain men like the wrong way not
just men with women too because a lot of
women are on that same tip where it's
like well we're women we have to be
ladies we can't be talking about our
sexual experiences because that's for
closed doors or whatever it is and like
a lot of people are just like so
repressed and so they see women like us
where we're not afraid to share our
experiences cuz I get those I get dams
too like you're such a [ __ ] like
talking about your social experiences
you're married like you have a your
mother like how could you like
you'reyou're so disrespecting your
family and all their mothers dick too so
why not a mother and a wife you could
completely be sexualized and I think
that thing is that like when you look at
feminism and I like when you look at the
definition of it it's equality between
men and women right so you're putting
them on level playing fields and we're
talking about stuff that for decades
centuries women were not allowed to talk
about and it's still got a stigma today
even though men have talked about it all
the time especially in media all over
the place like um and so it's kind of I
think whenever there's a paradigm shift
there's an overcorrect Ignace that
happens so you're gonna get people that
go way too far the other way and like
our like very I don't know like I'm just
like well I'm a FEMINIST and [ __ ] men
and they're they suck and you know what
feminism is not about yeah women being
better than men it's just it's just
about being is being free to do the same
things as men and to be based on
qualifications there's a lot of positive
discrimination going on right now
because of that overcorrecting where
women are being hired because they need
women representation and there's not
that argument that are you qualified or
they just hiring you because you're a
woman and they need to diversify so that
that goes into a whole another area but
as far as like letting a man talking
about how like you're so sexually free
but then you let a man ruin your
business that's not fair because she
wasn't letting a man ruin her business
she was letting someone that she thought
was more qualified than her if you put
them on even playing fields he had spent
way more time in the industry than her
and so she was seeking advice from
someone more qualified it didn't matter
that he was a man or a woman if she was
talking to a woman who was more
qualified I'm sure she'd follow her
advice too
and so that's why I feel like that whole
argument can be easily dismantled if you
really like look at the logistics of it
I have a problem with with that with
like because I think feminism especially
now is getting a really bad name and to
be honest I I didn't know what feminism
was until a few years ago when I said I
wasn't a feminist because I thought
feminists were just what man haters and
that they were just like our direction
yeah I didn't like the feminists or
people just run around it or protesting
with their tits out like that's that's
gonna win it like I don't really but
yeah but it's funny really quick they
are
just viewing this entire show like not
maybe like 20 minutes ago 15 minutes ago
we were saying like [ __ ] man I don't
think men are together like yeah man you
that right there is in addition to the
issue I have because like when we we say
things kind of jokingly but I guess it
does create some sort of environment
where people are like hey be careful of
what environment you're creating because
like you don't wanna go down that road
okay like I don't hate men I love men I
actually an issue with women I have
mommy issues okay my mom's a drug addict
I lost her very early my dad raised me I
have so much respect for men there's
like all the men in my life are so
valued to me even the men that are
in my life like Nikki's husband is very
valuable to him that guy so I know so
like I think Douga the gunner say he
don't man I would never say that and
then also like with us talking about sex
and stuff on the show like sometimes I
like me personally like I'll play it up
a bit like I've had different periods
where I've been single so I have a lot
of stories from different times and like
but do I think it's healthy to always be
[ __ ] different guys every week and
everything like that it's like no
there's there's a level of healthy like
sexual aberration and then there's just
being a [ __ ] because you have your own
issues and you and you can't settle down
you have no way of having real human
contact and there's just so much it's
difficult to be in this space it's
basically all I'm trying to samples yeah
there's it's it's hard and like watching
these girls kind of get torn down on top
of them already dealing with their own
like interpersonal issues I feel like
kind of bad for them we'll see you the
thing is is that we can say Ben are
trash or whatever jokingly like and then
we did at the beginning but we also say
[ __ ] as crazy it's not like we're
weird you know being discriminatory we
[ __ ] think everyone's crazy we're
crazy in different ways men are crazy in
one way and women can be crazy in
another way and that's just how that's
how we are and I don't know I just never
I never see it as one being better than
the other and also like you I feel like
I've had just as many men idols as I've
had women idols and I I don't think that
talking about sex and especially the way
that we talk about it I feel like you're
sharing stories from things that we've
learned from so it's not just like to
talk about it to brag about it to be
like I got [ __ ] in so many halls and
loved we're not like trying to be like
all again I'm [ __ ] master or whatever
it's just that we're speaking from
experiences of like what things that
we've learned from and what we've
learned about ourselves through those
experiences and how we didn't think
certain things were okay to talk about
in out we didn't we would shut up and
like just do whatever the man wanted us
to or like whatever like at certain
points in your life when you just don't
like you're very vulnerable and you
don't know enough yet and I think
sharing those experiences is super
healthy because it makes people out
there who might be going through it feel
like they're not alone and like they can
learn from our experiences and kind of
learn more about themselves and that way
too and that's all I've ever wanted from
sharing those stories I [ __ ] love my
husband and we have great
sex and we have [ __ ] marital sex it's
sanctioned under the Lord okay
missionary most times the Bible is
face-up in the bedroom door
Jesus candle and he watches over it you
better not literally seen about the
condoms next to the Jesus candle like
they because for a while we didn't want
to get pregnant but I didn't want to be
on birth control so I was getting my
body used to not being on birth control
but I also didn't want to get how do you
see things you know scientifically
proven a pullout method that I'm not
trying condon fiddling of being the
filled with semen I just run over there
and they don't think I could give that
up
Wow am ia [ __ ] now under the Lord I said
by the line at least you're not a lying
war drew true and I'm a loyal ass [ __ ]
you're loyal [ __ ] and that's the that's
the most important quality so a lot of
dick but it's the same dick I wish there
are more loyal [ __ ] it's so funny
because like we get those like mgtow
guys coming sometimes to our channel and
like those are the men going their own
way and they're like basically he-man
woman haters and they'll here's talking
about like like certain things and I
mean there's they take it so far or they
think that like we will never love
ourselves we'll never have husbands and
all that stuff and I'm like what the
charity two of them are married you know
I like we like we're and the other ones
are still pretty decent out
relationships too like there's a
difference between like with it's it's
like women I feel like back in the day
in the caveman times like they got to
sit around the fire and they got to knit
their [ __ ] little clothes and they
got to kind of talk about sex the kind
of talk [ __ ] about the guys or whatever
but like they were still women like that
we're taking care of my men and like
things were whatever it's like we're
just having our time in our moment to
like share our stories and stuff and
like I feel like the caller daddy girls
are doing the same thing it's like
that's our space as women to just kind
of talk [ __ ] guys go golfing and they
talk [ __ ] but then they go on to their
wives and they [ __ ] they get
controlled by their little wives and
like everything they balance
No so like it's just us talking [ __ ] and
like the girls the same way so like I
found I just don't hear any [ __ ]
about women talking the way they always
feel like I've shared more stories of me
being crazy yeah yeah that's just some
small dick energy talk from that article
yeah but I read that [ __ ] and I got
pissed I was like no that's great no I'm
glad you brought that up because I
that's I'm sure there's a huge chunk of
the public that does feel that way and
like look you're not gonna change
everyone's mind but I think that just
giving our perspective on it like when
we started this podcast is because we
were in a legit girls chat where we were
talking about all these things and we
all didn't know that other people were
going through it too and so it made us
feel like wow like there's someone to
talk to and if we could be that for
other people out there that like why not
like that's awesome yeah and a lot of
people have reached out and been like
thank you so much for talking about this
today and I love do evil in person too
like the like back way and like before
these times when I used to go to my yoga
class like could be girls going in and
be like oh my god come on I'm like won't
be God really thank you all the girls we
got really like they'd be telling me
like this is exactly what it what I mean
like I just feel like I'm best friends
with you guys and like it just feels it
makes me feel less alone
norge I'm like that's the whole point of
why we made this is awesome yeah that's
why I was scared of the numbers at first
because I didn't want us to lose that
like the fun and the like candidness and
you know at the same time like I do want
to touch base on like business-wise
people say and it's for a good reason
don't do businesses don't do business
with your friends because I've seen
friendships like decades-long
friendships break up within a span of a
few months that when they go into
business together and I everyone goes
into business with their friends like
yeah that's my best friend I'll never
screw me over they'll never change balla
but yeah it will change when money comes
into play dude like yeah [ __ ] change
no matter how long telling them so I can
tell you now from day one I don't care
if you guys have been
but buddies since birth since the womb
since the room if you guys are going
into business together have a contract
that paperwork get it for nine I don't
get a [ __ ] if you guys [ __ ] each other's
wives and it's fantastic and you love it
it's a great friendship if they get for
work done yeah honestly like to do okay
to clear up some like common
misconception that a lot of people have
apparently some people think that if you
present a contract on the table that's
immediately like a slap to the face to
the other person so in reality it says
you would relieve the opposite yeah the
exact opposite because you're you're
putting on the table saying hey I am
like willing to put my ass on the line
here
are you also like are you also willing
to to do the exact same thing that's not
a sign of respect
like it's not a sign of like oh I'm
gonna be doing some shady [ __ ] if you
bring up a contract no honey it's
literally the option question you don't
riddle me this how does that fair then
with the state is that the same thing as
a prenup because in my eyes I feel like
it's the same thing as getting a prenup
with your husband like if you both know
you ain't doing some [ __ ] up [ __ ] then
you got a prenup I'm like why why do
people find that offensive like like
it's okay seen I mean we didn't do it
right but I brought it up at one point
and I was like this seems fair like this
seems like whatever money you've made
and like outside of our relationship or
whatever that's yours what the [ __ ]
right and so why some women or some men
come into that they say here the word
prenup and they go absolutely not like
it's almost like well are you gonna
break it then yeah like why is this
actually free right I had never
understood that I mean to me it's like
well we didn't sign a prenup because
none of us had [ __ ] before we got
married yeah it was like I'm like I
don't know what you got going on that I
don't know about but if you whatever you
could protect it if you want it's on the
table
yeah I can understand like we until you
had nothing but my prenup would say
everything is fine like we'll split but
if you cheat on me I take everything you
own and half of your dick
I like that you'll get an extra
circumcision and Gina will keep it right
into a necklace
[ __ ] put that [ __ ] into a little pill
and hold it around exactly every time I
started getting out the words the men
are gonna ask them what's that necklace
I'm like that's gonna be my ex's [ __ ]
dick that's my no cheating no cheating
mm-hmm and on that note [ __ ] are
crazy [ __ ] is crazy bro
but yeah thank you guys so much for
tuning in we just we saw this and it's
happening right now and we were all
talking about it and we're like you know
what we should really talk about it in a
in a big boot episode and we didn't want
to come out like weeks from now we just
wanted to give you a bonus episode and
talk about it now because it's really
interesting and it's interesting all of
our thoughts on it yeah so there you go
it's been a big mood hasn't it yeah it
has go Alex again daddy gay I'm not
daddy gang but maybe I'll be daddy gay
now that Alex is all go Alex yeah
release is something that's very there's
some barbells there yes yes go go Alex
first baby sure you later
later y'all bye